bien chers collègues nous allons
reprendre les travaux de la commission
nous accueillons ce soir monsieur le
garde des sceaux avec pour objectif
d'évoquer évidemment le budget de la
justice par l’année 2023 je rappelle que
notre commission est saisie pour avis
chacun le sait pour la mission justice
judiciaire
et nous avons trois rapporteurs sur la
justice judiciaire et l'accès aux droits
mesdames canaillé Verrien sur
l'administration pénitentiaire notre
collègue à la marque et sur la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
madame Maryse carraire je rappelle à
tout le monde que notre entre notre
audition pardon et retransmise en direct
sur le site internet du Sénat et
monsieur le ministre
nous après le point budgétaire que nous
aurons que vous allez nous présenter et
des questions des collègues nous venons
je voudrais que nous venons d'entendre
le général de gendarmerie qui est venu
nous parler de l'organisation de la
gendarmerie en matière de police
judiciaire et je pense qu'il y aura
peut-être de la part de Madame bellureau
et de Monsieur Durin quelques questions
à vous adresser mais sans tarder je vous
laisse la parole tout de suite
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur spécial mesdames
Messieurs les rapporteurs pour avis
mesdames mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
projets de budget vous soumettre
témoigne pour la troisième année
consécutive
de l'importance qu'attache le
gouvernement obligé du ministère de la
Justice
se sont ainsi 710 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui viendront abonder en
2023 le service public de la justice
qui s'élèverait à
9,6 milliards d'euros pour 2023 soit
vous l'avez compris une hausse de 8%
. ses moyens
importants permettront de nourrir les
trois piliers de mon action
l'augmentation
du budget de la justice judiciaire de 9
% et je sais que c'est un enjeu sensible
pour vous madame la sénatrice canaillé
pour atteindre
3,39 milliards d'euros pour 2023
deuxième pilier l'augmentation des
moyens de l'administration pénitentiaire
monsieur le sénateur Marc
de plus de 7% soit un budget de
3,891 milliards d'euros pour 2023
n'oublie pas bien sûr madame la
sénatrice Carrère protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse qui bénéficiera d'une
hausse de plus de
10%. merci atteignant
donc 917 millions d'euros pour 2023
mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ce projet de budget si
l'on regarde un peu en arrière
représente une hausse de plus de 26% du
budget de la justice depuis mon arrivée
en 2020 et un peu plus de 40% depuis
l'élection du Président de la République
monsieur le président
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs et
sénateurs je sais votre commission
particulièrement sensible à la question
des moyens
au-delà de clivages partisans je sais
que votre commission
a souvent plaidé pour une considération
accrue des politiques gouvernementales
en faveur de la justice
elle avait même en son temps
plaider pour une trajectoire de hausse
du budget supérieur à celle prévue à
l'époque par le gouvernement lors de la
loi de programmation pour la justice
de 2019 et il se trouve que nous avons
une fine même dépasser les propositions
pourtant ambitieuses du Sénat
dans l'exécution de cette LPJ via les
deux derniers hausses de 8% en
2021 2022 c'est donc
que nous nous retrouvons sur cet enjeu
démocratique majeur que constitue la
bonne santé de notre justice
alors que vous avez été l'une des
chevilles ouvriers des états généraux de
la justice monsieur le Président et que
le Sénat avait organisé les Agora de la
justice en septembre 2021 je suis venu
vous proposer qu'ensemble nous
poursuivions avec responsabilité et
ambition c'est indispensable effort de
renforcement de notre justice fondement
de notre pacte social
c'est donc un nouvel effort budgétaire
inédit que je vous propose que je suis
venu ce soir vous présenter
je persiste et je signe sans aucune
acrimonie ce budget va nous permettre de
poursuivre le rattrapage de plus de 30
ans
d'abandon politique
budgétaire humain
et nous pourrons mettre en œuvre les
recommandations de grande qualité
issues des états généraux de la justice
au premier rang dont toutes les
propositions celle d'un plan massif de
recrutement
1500 magistrats
1500 greffiers
décontractuels et au total 10 000
personnes qui seront
embauchés si vous le voulez bien on va
rentrer dans le détail
de ces crédits
je l'ai dit ma priorité numéro 1 est
celle du renforcement humain massif
dont notre justice a besoin les crédits
de la mission justice du projet de loi
de finance permettront l'amorce d'un
plan inédit de recrutement
je viens dans
d'en parler de plus de 10000 emplois
supplémentaires pérennes et ce plan sera
mis en place d'ici bien sûr 2027
certains ont pu me reprocher l'usage de
mot forme et c'est bien des mots forts
pour décrire des actes qui sont forts et
ce à plusieurs titres
par rapport au quinquennat précédent
qui avait permis la création de
7270 emplois
nous allons donc
faire mieux et plus
dans le cadre de ce nouveau quinquennat
par rapport aux effectifs qui existent
au ministère ensuite puisque nous
augmenterons de
11%, les emplois du ministère d'ici
2027 en termes de comparaison ces
proportionnellement quatre fois plus que
les recrutements réalisés pour la police
et la gendarmerie car oui nous avons
décidé d'amorcer un véritable rattrapage
conformément aux orientations qui ont
été prises depuis deux ans et aux
recommandations des du rapport des États
généraux
nous allons d'ores et déjà créer 1500
postes de magistrats 1500 postes de
greffiers supplémentaires sur le
quinquennat afin de renforcer de façon
significative les effectifs en
juridiction c'est un effort très
important puisque ces créations
représentent le double de ce qui a été
fait lors du précédent
les autres emplois seront répartis
finement
année après année en fonction des
besoins opérationnels résultant à la
fois des campagnes de recrutement qui
seront mises en place et bien sûr de
l'avancement des projets immobiliers
portés par le ministère de la Justice en
particulier à la construction
d'établissements pénitentiaires
dès 2023 ce sont 2253 personnels qui
arriveront dans les établissements
pénitentiaires dans les juridictions et
dans les structures de protection
judiciaires de la jeunesse soit 3 fois
plus que les recrutements qui ont été
réalisés en 2022 c'est 2253 personnels
supplémentaires sont répartis de la
façon suivante 1220 pour la justice
judiciaire
avec notamment 200 magistrats
et 191 greffiers 809 personnels
supplémentaires pour l'administration
pénitentiaire
92 pour la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse le reste soit 132 personnels
bénéficiera à la coordination et la
politique publique de la justice
60 créations d'emplois sont prévues pour
les opérateurs 26 pour l'École nationale
de la magistrature
19 pour l'agence publique pour
l'immobilier de la justice 15 pour
l'agence de gestion et de recouvrement
des avoir saisis et confisqués
la grâce deuxièmement ma deuxième
priorité découle bien sûr de la première
pour recruter et reconstruire un service
public de la justice de qualité il nous
faut attirer et fidéliser les
compétences par des revalorisations
catégorielles des agents du ministère
qui sont autant de rouages
indispensables à son bon fonctionnement
pour assurer ce niveau inédit de
recrutement je souhaite renforcer encore
l'attractivité des métiers de justice
par des revalorisations salariales
nos métiers sont exigeants je pense bien
sûr à l'engagement des magistrats mais
aussi bien sûr à l'expertise des
greffiers à la délicate et difficile
mission des surveillants pénitentiaires
aux compétences de nos cadres à
l'engagement des éducateurs de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse ou
au dévouement des personnels
administratifs et techniques qui
travaillent souvent dans le nombre mais
sont qui bien sûr la justice ne
fonctionnerait pas
le projet de budget 2023
permettra de revaloriser tous les agents
de ce ministère de façon inédite à
hauteur de 80 millions d'euros et si
vous le voulez nous entrerons bien sûr
tout à l'heure dans le détail
mais
il convient cependant à ce stade
d'évoquer
d'abord la situation des magistrats
madame la rapporteur canaillé j'ai
décidé de revaloriser les primes des
magistrats à hauteur de 1000 euros bruts
par mois en moyenne soit une hausse de
plus de 16% de leur rémunération globale
cette mesure est nécessaire pour
maintenir
l'attractivité de ce métier
pour maintenir
une comparaison avec la rémunération des
magistrats de l'ordre administratif
il est aussi légitime pour témoigner
de notre reconnaissance de la mienne en
particulier au magistrats de l'ordre
judiciaire qui travaillent au quotidien
au service de notre justice
je veux prendre ici un exemple concret
précis de l'abandon politique humain
financier de la justice que j'évoquais
précédemment
le régime indemnitaire
n'avait pas été augmenté à part quelques
revalorisations spécifiques à certaines
fonctions depuis 1996
depuis 1996 c'est-à-dire depuis Jacques
Toubon garde des sources
pas Défenseur des droits
ensuite
concernant les fonctionnaires
2023 sera encore une année historique
avec une enveloppe catégorienne de 50
millions d'euros soit une hausse de plus
de 20% en un an et de 66% en 2 ans
c'était 40 millions d'euros en 2022 30
millions d'euros en 2021
j’amplifierai ainsi l'effort consacré
depuis trois ans aux deux objectifs de
la politique que je poursuis
l'attractivité de tous les métiers de la
justice qui sont tous des rouages
absolument indispensables et bien sûr la
fidélisation des femmes et des hommes
qui travaillent au service de la justice
de notre pays je souhaiterais
évoquer devant vous la poursuite de
l'effort inédit consacré à la
revalorisation indemnitaire dégraissiez
et directeur des services de greffe
après l'augmentation de 21 millions
d'euros obtenus pour 2022 c'est plus de
10 millions d'euros qui seront consacrés
à cette fin en 2023 pour les greffiers
c'est une augmentation de 12% dont vont
bénéficier les personnels de greffe au
total sur trois ans avec les hausses
prévues bien sûr en 203
la revalorisation à hauteur de 7
millions du régime indemnitaire des
agents de la Protection Judiciaire de la
Jeunesse madame la sélectrice carraire
concernant enfin les surveillants
pénitentiaires sénateur Marc ils ont
bénéficié en 2022 d'une réforme
importante de leur statut de leur
rémunération la fusion des grades de
surveillants et de brigadier a permis de
simplifier la carrière des agents et de
revaloriser de façon importante le
salaire indiciaire notamment en début et
en fin de carrière
mais cette réforme était une première
étape
des travaux seront engagés dès le début
de l'année 2023 avec les organisations
syndicales pour travailler à une
revalorisation d'envergure de leur
statut et de leur rémunération qui sera
mise en œuvre dans les années suivantes
nous devons en effet pour ouvrir les
établissements pénitentiaires du plan
15000 nous devrez évidemment tous les
moyens pour recruter plus et dans de
meilleures conditions pour là encore
fidéliser les agents qui exercent des
missions nécessaires
mais tellement difficile nous le savons
bien évidemment tous ici la poursuite
des actions menées pour revaloriser le
régime indemnitaire des agents de
catégories C et je n'oublie pas bien sûr
les cadres de ce ministère près de 10
millions d'euros seront consacrés cette
année à une revalorisation de leur
régime indemnitaire mais également
indiciaire
nous travaillons à la construction de
parcours professionnel plus attractif
plus variées et plus riche c'est une
évolution légitime que nous leur devons
regarde leur investissement quotidien
aux côtés de chacun et de chacune
troisièmement troisième axe budgétaire
est simple
après les recrutements de magistrats et
de greffier il nous faut assurer
l'effectivité de notre réponse pénale et
améliorer les conditions de travail des
agents
et de détention de détenus auquel nous
sommes ici tous sensibles et pour ça je
souhaite doter notre pays d'au moins
15000 places de prison net
supplémentaires à horizon 2027
ce plan lancé par le Président de la
République qui a été marqué
assez début par des difficultés
notamment
inhérente aux recherches foncières
parfois pour des raisons de faisabilité
technique
environnementale la découverte d'espèces
animales protégées
je gage que de nombreux élus locaux ici
présents voient de quoi je parle mais
également
je me dois de le redire
pour des raisons d'acceptabilité
de la part des élus et
disons le clairement dériverains
elle a également été entravée par des
démarches contentieuses lourdes
certaines d'ailleurs ne sont pas
terminées je pense à Muret
trembler en France ou Orléans
mais maintenant que les terrains
nécessaires au lancement de l'ensemble
des projets sont tous
identifiés les opérations entre dans
leur phase active et le rythme des
livraisons va maintenant s'accélérer
progressivement pour s'échelonner
jusqu'à 2027
aussi très attentif sur ces questions
monsieur le rapporteur spécial Antoine
Lefebvre en 2023 ce sont plus de
441 millions d'euros qui sont budgétés
pour la réalisation du programme 15000
et je tiens à vous rassurer
si certaines sous-consommation de crédit
ont pu être constaté ces dernières
années s'agissant des crédits
immobiliers de telles sous-consommation
n'auront sous taux de réserve plus lieu
à l'avenir car je l'ai dit tous les
terrains sont
identifiés je vous rendrai compte
naturellement de l'évolution de ces
sous-consommation et j'en suis convaincu
de leur disparition
dans le détail
en 2023 c'est 441 millions d'euros
permettront de finaliser la livraison de
10 établissements pénitentiaires soit un
cinquième du plan 15000 voici
concrètement les lieux concernés
SAS
Avignon Valence mot
osni Le Mans Montpellier ou quand
il s'agit enfin des trois centres
pénitentiaires qui ouvriront à Caen
Fleury-Mérogis trois Lavaux que j'ai pu
visiter en juillet dernier pour être
plus précis encore dès 2024
la moitié des établissements du plan
15000 seront opérationnels sur la
cinquantaine de chantiers actuellement
en cours de plus
de plus à le rejoue je vous parle ce
sont 18 opérations qui sont en chantier
avancées dans toute la France par
exemple une nouvelle construction des
Baumettes à Marseille 740 places où la
réhabilitation de l'ex-centre de jeunes
détenus de Fleury-Mérogis qui permettra
la création de 400 oui nouvelle places
enfin je souhaite également engager les
opérations de réhabilitation
absolument nécessaire des établissements
pénitentiaires les plus vétustes en
particulier l'opération majeure et
prioritaire de réhabilitation du centre
pénitentiaire de Fresnes
contrairement à ce que certains ont pu
dire
c'est tout sauf le Club Med je crois
d'ailleurs que tous les parcs de loisirs
et toute l'hôtellerie
a permis de
colorer les fantasmes de certains
celui qui dit ça vous le savez au mieux
au mieux totalement
ignorant de l'univers karzeral au pire
il est motivé par des intentions
bassement démagogique
et je dis ce mot devant une commission
qui depuis des années a porté la
question carcérale à la question
carcérale une attention toute
particulière je veux ici en remercier je
suis d'ailleurs très fier d'avoir porté
la loi buffet
qui a créé le recours pour conditions
indignes de détention et c'est dans ce
même esprit que nous renforcerons nos
budgets de rénovation du parc carcéral
déjà existant
quatrièmement et j'avance
après les recrutements massifs
l'attractivité enforcée des métiers de
justice il faut également prévoir et
préparer l'accueil de recrutement par
des investissements massifs dans
l'immobilier de nos juridictions
c'est un enjeu évidemment essentiel pour
une justice de qualité pour tout d'abord
mieux accueillir les justiciables bien
sûr car c'est d'abord eux que c'est
d'abord pour eux que la justice
travaille mais aussi bien sûr pour
améliorer les conditions de travail des
agences actuelles et des renforts
humains dans les 5 années à venir alors
en la matière le projet le projet budget
permettra en 2023 de poursuivre les
opérations d'ampleur qui ont été
engagées lors du quinquennat précédent
notamment il s'agit de poursuivre les
chantiers des palais de justice de Lille
de l'île de la Cité à Paris de Bayonne
et d'autres projets encore de poursuivre
les études
de projets de Cayenne de pucées de mots
de Moulins de Nancy de Nantes de
Perpignan et d'autres projets encore et
enfin pour permettre de lancer de
nouvelles opérations immobilières comme
à Argentan
Chartres Colmar un Colmar Saint-Brieuc
ou Verdun
ma présentation serait incomplète si je
n'évoquais pas des mesures importantes
que je compte porter avec ce budget les
frais de justice d'abord avec une
enveloppe de 660 millions d'Euros pour
renforcer les moyens d'enquête et
d'expertise de la justice soit une
hausse de 12 millions d'euros
supplémentaires
ceci porte à 170 millions d'euros les
forces consentis sur ces moyens depuis
mon arrivée et cet effort contribuera
notamment à faciliter le déstockage des
affaires
d'ores et déjà en cours et dont nous
reparlerons si vous le souhaitez
les crédits d'investissement
informatique qui sont un enjeu essentiel
pour le ministère et que votre collègue
Dominique Verrien qui nous regarde
mais qui nous regardent m'attendait et
que je salue par vision interposée
et puis si elle n'est pas branchée sur
la vision vous la saluerez de ma part
alors ces crédit d'investissement
informatique seront portés à 195
millions d'euros dans le cadre la
poursuite de la mise en oeuvre du plan
de transformation numérique ministériel
ces crédits concernent principalement la
mise en oeuvre des grands projets
informatiques comme Astrea à Tiger 360
Portalis ou encore PPN la procédure
pénale numérique en parallèle
la mise à niveau technique des
infrastructures telles que les centres
de production et le réseau seront
renforcés et
des informaticiens des techniciens
seront déployés massivement dans toutes
les juridictions
oui
on sait bien oui je partage votre avis
monsieur le président
c'est bien oui c'est bien parce que
quand on quand une panne intervient
vendredi à
16h30 dans une juridiction on a beau
appeler la DJ je pense qu'on n'est pas
dépanner tout de suite donc
je mesure me semble-t-il de bon sens les
crédits de l'accès aux droits et à la
médiation vont s'élever à 713 millions
d'euros en 2023 ce qui représente une
hausse de 33 millions d'euros par
rapport à 2022 plus 5% avec
641 millions d'euros pour les crédits
dédiés à l'aide juridictionnel ce qui
équivaut à une hausse de 26 millions
d'euros en une année
nous lancerons
d'ailleurs prochainement un grand plan
de l'amiable dans la suite des États
généraux afin de faire basculer
la culture judiciaire française
en faveur d'une véritable culture du
règlement amiable mais j'aurais bien sûr
l'occasion de vous en parler lors de la
présentation du plan d'action issus des
états généraux de la justice que nous
sommes en train de de finaliser
43 millions pour l'aide aux victimes
c'est une hausse de 7% ce qui traduit
évidemment l'importance que que nous
portons tout ce que je porte à cette
politique
qui constitue bien sûr une priorité
gouvernementale est très important
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs de
cette enveloppe
16,1 million d'euros seront dédiés aux
violences intrafamilales
marquant plus qu'un doublement du budget
violence intrafamiliale annuelles qui
étaient de 8 millions d'euros à mon
arrivée en 2020
mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs le projet de budget 2023
qui s'approche désormais des 10
milliards d'euros pour la justice
nous permettra de poursuivre le
renforcement indispensable de notre
justice avec une ambition inédite tout
en étant dans la certitude pour les
services de mon ministère d'exécuter au
mieux ce projet de budget ambition
responsabilité voilà résumé en deux mots
mon projet de budget pour 2023
cela nous le devons magistrat au
greffier aux agents pénitentiaires aux
avocats aux adjoints administratifs au
juristes assistants il y a tous les
acteurs du monde judiciaire qui rendent
chaque jour possible
le contrat social je parle ici de
préserver la paix sociale d'une part la
confiscation du droit à la vengeance à
travers la loi pénale et d'autre part le
règlement tous les litiges du quotidien
qui minent la société
mais cette ambition cette responsabilité
nous la devons avant tout au justiciable
autrement dit
nos concitoyens qui payent aujourd'hui
les abandons et les renoncements du
passé
ce budget vous propose de poursuivre de
manière accélérée le renforcement de
notre justice j'espère bien sûr pouvoir
compter comme les deux années
précédentes sur votre appui mais avant
cela je répondrai si ma voix ne me lâche
pas
naturellement et avec plaisir à toutes
les questions que voudrait bien me poser
merci Monsieur le Ministre on va vous
laisser quelques temps de répit avec une
série de questions
en premier les rapporteurs madame
canaillé monsieur Lamarck puis madame
Maryse Carrère
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux effectivement pour la
troisième année consécutive vous nous
présenter un budget de la justice en
hausse et nous pouvons que nous en
félicité
cette augmentation des crédits permet de
rattraper il est certain un retard fort
et de remettre la justice sur une bonne
trajectoire alors ce premier budget
poste est à généraux de la justice
préfigure le plan d'action que vous nous
avez annoncé
il propose sur le trépied que vous avez
présenté et sur un renforcement
effectivement des moyens d'évolu à la
nuit à la justice judiciaire notamment
par un renforcement des moyens humains
qui est une attente forte dans les
juridictions notamment auprès des
magistrats par des rec vraiment
important prévu néanmoins l'effet enfin
l'objectif recherché est avant tout pour
renouer la confiance
d'agir sur la réduction des délais de
jugement qui restent une des difficultés
récurrentes et donc je voudrais savoir
tout d'abord si
les augmentations
d'emploi notamment sous la forme des
fameux contractuels qui ont été
embauchés les années précédentes et deux
dernières années ont permis de réduire
véritablement en matière civile
notamment les délais traitements des
affaires alors que il semble qu'il y ait
toujours un délai de plus d'une année en
2021 donc pensez-vous que on nous allons
pouvoir passer une étape supplémentaire
avec des annonces dans votre budget
deuxièmement si l'attractivité des
fonctions de magistrats passent par une
revalorisation de la rémunération
notamment pour les magistrats
judiciaires comme vous l'avez annoncé
avec ses primes qui restent déprime mais
qui sont quand même substantielles 2000
euros brut par mois il semble que
l'attractivité de la profession repose
aussi sur le sens donné à l'action des
magistrats et notamment sur une réforme
plus structurelle de l'organisation
autour de l'équipe du magistrat alors
que pensez-vous du rapport de Madame
Lottin et pensez-vous qu'il sera
transposable rapidement de même où en
est-on dans l'évaluation de la charge du
travail des magistrats et puis une
question alors j'aurais dû le dire en
introduction parce que vous avez cité ma
choraporteur madame Dominique Verrien
qui nous entend mais ne peut parler donc
je poserai une question en son nom sur
un sujet qui lui tient à cœur celui de
l'informatique
en effet afin de ne pas reproduire les
erreurs du passé
notamment même s'il y a une conduction
des équipes en cours
quelle réflexion menez-vous pour mettre
en place les préconisations notamment
des états généraux de la justice pour
prendre en compte les évolutions
informatiques nécessaires notamment dans
Portalis prévoyez-vous un pilotage par
des équipes compétentes notamment par
une agence du numérique
merci
à Lamarque
merci président monsieur le ministre
pour la troisième année consécutive le
budget de la justice augmente fortement
pourriez-vous nous dire quelques mots de
l'exécution de celui-ci pour les
collectivités on appelle on appelle cela
la le compte administratif donc nous
aimerions savoir ce qu'il en est
deuxième question nous sommes en train
de bâtir des prisons après voir d'autres
l'augmentation des matières premières et
du coût de la construction ne va-t-il
pas impacter
notre programme troisième question pour
rendre plus attractif les métiers de la
pénitentiaire des revalorisations
indemnitaires et vous l'avez dit sont
nécessaires et même prévu mais il ne
faudrait-il pas jouer aussi sur d'autres
leviers comme l'accès au logement parce
que nous savons que pour les surveiller
un pénitentiaires notamment lorsqu'ils
sont affectés en région parisienne c'est
un vrai problème que de trouver un
logement et j'ai entendu parler d'un
projet de construction de 80 logements à
Fleury-Mérogis qui me paraît prometteur
nous avons aussi identifié je crois
d'autres lieux où nous pourrions
d'ailleurs avec avec des organismes
d'HLM pourquoi pas ce qui ne coûterait
finalement rien à l'administration
paysagère et qui n'impacterait pas le
budget de la justice ou en est-on sur ce
sujet là et puis quatrième question avec
le président François Noël buffet nous
sommes rendus à Mayotte l'année dernière
au mois de septembre et il nous avait
apparu comme nécessaire je pense que
vous-même quand vous y êtes allés il est
apparu nécessaire que nous ayons un
nouveau centre pénitentiaire ou en étant
de ce dernier merci merci Monsieur Marc
madame Carrère
merci monsieur le Président
j'aurais deux questions à vous poser
monsieur le ministre mais d'abord je
fais le même constat que mes collègues
sur le budget de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse qui est aussi
en augmentation à nouveau cette année et
nous nous en félicitons vous l'avez
signalé une augmentation conséquente des
recrutements encore une fois en 2023
comme en 2022 et cependant nous ne
pouvons que nous inquiéter sur les
difficultés de recrutement que connaît
la PJJ avec un taux de vacances des
postes de près de 6% et un niveau de
turn over élevé sur plusieurs postes
difficiles avec des taux de contractuel
aussi dans la PJJ et de et le
renouvellement aussi très élevé alors
Monsieur le Ministre ma première
question sera ce quels sont les pistes
étudiées pour rendre attractif les
métiers de la PJJ aujourd'hui comment
vous pensez remédier à ce problème grave
alors même que vous créez de nouveaux
postes qui sont nécessaires pour des
actions qui reposent beaucoup sur la
présence et les liens tissés sur la
durée avec les jeunes ma deuxième
question je serai pas plus longue vous
avez et je parle sous sous le contrôle
ou le couvert de notre collègue Tani
Mohammed swahili vous avez annoncé la
création d'un nouveau centre éducatif
fermé à Mayotte
celle-ci répond bien sûr aux besoins et
à la demande des élus et mais il se pose
la question de savoir si ce centre
éducatif fermé sera confiée au secteur
public ou au secteur privé et au regard
du besoin de réaffirmation de la
présence de l'État dans ce département
il me semblait qu'un établissement
public serait peut-être à privilégier
dans ma question est simple c'est Carla
décision sur le caractère public ou
associatif de cet établissement
sera-t-elle prise je vous remercie merci
tous les rapporteurs sont exprimés les
autres collègues madame
cette augmentation budget nous satisfait
beaucoup
de répondre à tous ses besoins qui
étaient énormes en matière de justice et
on se félicite de ses efforts
vous avez annoncé que d'ici 2027 il y
aura 1500 magistrats et 1500 gifiés de
plus qu'en 2022 pourriez-vous nous
confirmer qu'il s'agisse bien de une
hausse nette c'est à dire qu'elle prend
en compte les départs en retraite c'est
une occasion ici en commission des lois
de le préciser compte tenu de la
pyramide des âges ce nombre de départ en
retraite sera encore très important
jusqu'en 2027 s'il s'agit d'une os nette
combien de futurs magistrats et de
futurs greffiers formerez-vous chaque
année
au-delà d'une hausse du budget de l'ENS
qu'avez-vous prévu pour les accueillir
et de d'accueillir ces promotions qui
sont nettement plus importantes parce
que le nm est quand même
restreinte au niveau de sa superficie
selon vous monsieur le garde des sceaux
l'objectif en termes d'effectif que
c'est fixé le gouvernement à 2027 est-il
le nombre idéal de magistrats et de
greffiers dans la France a besoin pour
rendre une bonne justice une justice
rapide au sein de laquelle les
professionnels disposeraient du temps
nécessaire pour traiter chaque affaire
individuellement calmement sagement car
aujourd'hui tous les avocats nous
interpellent sur les délais qui
s'allonge ma collègue vous la signalez
aussi dans toutes les juridictions et ce
nombre de magistrats devraient y
pourvoir
merci Madame l'herbier madame arrivée
puis monsieur Sueur
monsieur les moyens comme vous l'avez
souligné mais au-delà
au-delà de l'augmentation des moyens ce
qui est aussi intéressant c'est qu'il y
a souvent une une refonte structurelle
comme la soulignait Agnès canaye sur
cette question de la justice deux
petites questions très très précises sur
le programme 107 qui concerne
l'administration pénitentiaire vous vous
prévoyez
une augmentation de
de ces PIP et de dpip
indépendamment de l'augmentation des
postes se pose un réel problème
d'attractivité donc c'est une question
qui a été posée et là on rejoint la
question un peu structurelle qu'est-ce
que vous prévoyez comme comme élément
pour que cette question d'attractivité
soit
résolu et puis la deuxième question
c'est celle des des centres éducatifs
fermés qui dans les choix budgétaires
qui sont faits on a l'impression que on
confirme cette ce choix des centres
éducatifs fermés or nous venons de
rendre avec trois autres collègues un
rapport sur la délinquance des jeunes et
le décrochage scolaire et on s'interroge
en effet sur l'efficacité et la raison
d'être de ces CEF et donc
il y a des chantiers en retard là dessus
j'aimerais que vous puissiez nous dire
ce que vous en pensez parce que là aussi
les États généraux ont soulevé un
certain nombre de doutes sur cette
question là et comme vous avez dit que
c'était un excellent rapport avec
d'excellentes suggestions qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez vous pouvez en conclure là
dessus merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
Madame Marie Monsieur Jean-Pierre Sueur
puis monsieur tanimametzwali
oui monsieur le garde des sceaux je
voulais vous interroger après avoir bien
entendu constater l'augmentation des
crédits je voulais vous interroger sur
la question de la surpopulation
pénitentielle en effet comme vous savez
il y a aujourd'hui
72350 détenus pour
60709 places ce qui fait que le taux de
sur
occupation et de
141,5% dans les maisons d'arrêt et que
plus de 2000 personnes sont aujourd'hui
dans des cellules où il y a trois
personnes dans 9 mètres carrés sur des
matelas qui sont posés par terre
et je voulais vous demander tout
simplement
qu'est-ce que vous comptez faire dans
les mois qui viennent non pas de plus
long terme mais dans les mois qui
viennent par rapport à cette situation
là parce que c'est un vrai sujet que
vous connaissez bien nous avons pu lire
les conclusions des États généraux
un rapport écrit par des personnes
éminentes
qui dit que je cite la construction de
nouveaux établissements pénitentiaires
entre guillemets ne peut constituer une
réponse adéquate dit cela parce que sans
doute pense-t-il qu'il faut bien sûr ce
dont vous avez parlé réparer les
établissements qui doivent l'être mais
surtout qu'il faut une autre politique
qui privilégie les peines alternatives à
l'incarcération et à cet égard on est
quand même assez loin du but puisque le
taux que je viens de rappeler les
chiffres que je viens de rappeler sont
pratiquement sans précédent
voilà la question que je voulais vous
poser merci super
mon tour je me félicite de cette
augmentation
historique du budget de la justice
nous
voyons vraiment que l'on prend le
taureau par ses cornes je voudrais aussi
me réjouir d'entendre d'avoir entendu
les collègues de la commission des lois
parler de mon département
c'est certainement la suite de cette
mission monsieur le Président que vous
avez
effectué que la commission des lois a
effectuer sur ce territoire en grande
difficulté et c'est important que
d'autres collègues de la représentation
nationale puisse s'emparer aussi de ces
sujets et merci chers collègues de votre
de votre solidarité
je l'ai gardé ça vous avez effectué un
certain nombre d'annonces
relatives à Mayotte certains ont été
rappelés par par mes collègues une
nouvelle cité judiciaire
ce gros centre pénitentiaire le centre
éducatif fermé que Maryse a évoqué tout
à l'heure
ces annonces étaient nécessaires parce
que les besoins sont énormes
et dans le prolongement de ce que a dit
Marc quel est le calendrier
pour
ces
annonces
dans le besoin se fait criant
parce que
les délinquants et les criminels
n'attendent pas le temps joue contre
nous les délinquants et criminels sont à
l'oeuvre
il y a deux semaines la somme des élus
de Mayotte unanimement ont organisé une
opération il morte pour encore une fois
et bien stigmatiser la montée extrême de
la violence dans ce dans ce département
donc en attendant la réalisation de ces
projets qui prendra forcément du temps
qu'est-ce qui pourrait être fait
qu'est-ce qui pourrait être fait pour
traiter notamment la montée de la
délinquance juvénile et la montée de
cette de cette criminalité
est-ce que il ne serait pas monsieur le
gardeesso
qu'est-ce qu'il ne serait pas pertinent
de mettre en place une entité
spécialisée spéciale pour conduire
l'ensemble de ces projets d'autant plus
que du côté du ministre de l'intérieur
des brigades de gendarmerie
supplémentaires ont été annoncés des
logements supplémentaires pour ces
gendarmes ont été annoncés et pour la
justice également or vous le savez nous
avons affaire à un énorme problème de
foncier il ne faudrait pas que là encore
le foncier viennent retarder
ces évolutions c'est se concrétisations
nécessaires et et attendu donc est-ce
que une entité une sorte de commission
sans que ça soit un machin de plus
n'est pas nécessaire pour que l'ensemble
de ces projets dans ce petit territoire
puisse le plus rapidement possible voir
le jour et dans laquelle
les parlementaires prendraient leur
place mais aussi les autres acteurs de
la justice et merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur alors madame de la
ganterie puis ensuite monsieur benaroche
monsieur le ministre répondra merci
président monsieur le garde des sceaux
vous avez fait état d'une augmentation
de
des lignes de crédit concernant les
violences intrafamidales est-ce que vous
pourriez en préciser l'objet et indiquer
si vous avez prévu dans ces crédits la
création d'une juridiction spécialisée
consacrée à la lutte contre la violence
intrafamilale et les violences faites
aux femmes merci Madame Gontrie monsieur
Guy benaroche
la plupart des questions que je voulais
poser ont été posées donc juste une
précision
c'est droit de suite en quelque sorte au
débat sur les états généraux vous avez
questionné ma collègue on a parlé déjà
sur les dépips donc sur la
revalorisation des dépits qui a
particuliers c'est très corporatif mais
enfin c'est important pour pour ceux
dont tu as parlé Malam arriver sur en
particulier
sur l'attractivité de cette de ce métier
donc je voulais savoir ce qui était
prévu pour eux merci
merci Monsieur benaroche pas d'autres
questions
tout le monde s'est exprimé
et bien nous allons donner la parole
regarde des sous
merci monsieur le Président bon d'abord
madame la sénatrice canailler
l'évaluation le travail sur le
l'évaluation de la charge de travail
je l'ai demandé pratiquement quand je
suis arrivé il faut beaucoup de temps
pour le mettre en œuvre et je pense que
nous aurons
la DJ estime que ce travail sera terminé
pour la fin de l'année nous aurons cet
outil à disposition il est
indispensable et nous aurons en 2023 et
nous aurons en 2023 une idée précise des
besoins de recrutement de magistrats
je passe du du coq à l'âne si vous me
permettez cette expression est-ce que
les chiffres que nous avons annoncé sont
les bons chiffres sont en tous les cas
les chiffres qui ont été retenus par les
États généraux
après un travail dont je rappelle qu'il
est un travail
auprès de tous les acteurs du monde
judiciaire
garde des sceaux exclus d'une certaine
façon puisque les différents ateliers de
travail moi je n'ai pas souhaité y
participer
et le comité des États généraux je n'y
étais pas non plus de telle sorte qu'on
ne puisse pas dire que j'avais d'une
certaine façon orienter les travaux
voilà je les ai pris de cette façon
quand ils ont été restitués par le
président sauvé
et puis ensuite on a fait des
concertations avec tout le monde tous
ceux qui ont voulu venir sont venus tout
le monde est venu d'ailleurs à
l'exception je crois d'un syndicat de
magistrat qui n'a pas souhaité
participer participer à ces
concertations et nous avons retenu un
certain nombre de propositions
consensuelles j'ai voulu je pardon je
digresse un peu je reviens ensuite
précisément votre question mais je pense
que on a initié
je veux pas me gargariser de de mots
mais au fond d'une nouvelle gouvernance
parce que on n'est pas parti du
ministère pour essayer de de d'imposer
un certain nombre de choses on est parti
du comité des États généraux des
différents ateliers de travail
déconcertation nous avons
retenu les propositions qui étaient
consensuelles
et il me semblait nécessaire de le faire
et particulièrement nécessaire puisque
l'Assemblée nationale est aujourd'hui
composé comme vous le savez donc je
préfère arriver moi avec un projet de
loi
consensuel en tous les cas pour
l'ensemble des acteurs du monde
judiciaire et donc on a mis en place
cela le chiffre est-il le bon c'est un
chiffre qui ressort évidemment de ces
états généraux il faudra bien sûr
affiner ce chiffre sans aucun doute moi
je me méfie de ceux qui disent ces 1400
ou 2000 ou en entendu d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de chiffres absolument
invraisemblables certains chiffres
d'ailleurs
si nous avions Michelin en place nous
n'aurions pas su où faire travailler nos
magistrats bon et il en va de même pour
les greffiers
donc voilà ma réponse sur l'évaluation
de la charge de travail sur l'évolution
des méthodes de travail il y a quelque
chose qui est
qui est ressorti de ces états généraux
c'est et c'est un peu un changement de
paradigme ça c'est la nécessité de
mettre en place une équipe autour du
magistrat
ça répond à des préoccupations qui sont
différentes
on se souvient tous de la tribune qui a
été signée à l'initiative d'abord de
jeunes magistrats puis ensuite d'autres
magistrats et dégrifiés ont embrayé on
s'illustre
ils expriment au fond une perte de sens
ils expriment une forme de solitude on a
mis en place un tutorat mais ça n'est
sans doute pas suffisant c'était
nécessaire mais pas suffisant et cette
idée d'équipe autour du magistrat
à prospérer et tout le monde est
favorable à cela aujourd'hui alors qui
dans cette équipe
des universitaires en matière civile en
particulier mais pas que des greffiers
bien sûr et des contractuels
vous savez que un juriste assistant
auprès d'un magistrat c'est un jugement
qui a rendu deux fois plus vite ça c'est
quelque chose que l'on met en place et
on va recruter
00 juristes assistant dès 2023 je
m'arrêtais une toute petite seconde sur
la question que vous posez ce qui au
fond si je la résume si je me permets de
la résumer et ce qui sont efficaces et
contractuels en termes de déstockage
je vais vous rappeler que quand on les a
mis en place d'abord au mieux on va
regarder avec beaucoup de circonspection
et au pire c'était une
pluie battante de critique notamment
dans l'expression syndicale c'était mais
pourquoi vous allez chercher des
contractuels et pas des magistrats et
moi j'essayais de répondre
quand on me laissait l'espace suffisant
mais des magistrats il faut 31 mois pour
les former donc je vois pas où je vais
les trouver il y avait une forme
d'urgence d'urgence
c'est 2000 contractuels ils ont été
envoyés d'abord au pénal auprès des
procureurs puis ensuite
les civilistes se sont fait entendre
c'est pour moi le premier signe de ce
qu'on s'était pas trop trompé au fond
et
j'ai été conforté dans cette idée quand
on m'a demandé de les pérenniser c'est
pour moi la démonstration de ce que pour
le coup les juridictions les réclamer
moi je pensais qu'ils étaient
nécessaires et les juridictions m'ont
démontré qu'ils étaient indispensables
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait parce
que c'est ça la question est-ce que tout
ça ça a servi à quelque chose
aussi vive aujourd'hui on observe une
baisse des stocks
qui est comprise entre 15 et 28% selon
les matières et selon les juridictions
et ça entre le 1er janvier 2021 et l'ami
la baisse des stocks
se traduit en particulier par la montée
en puissance progressive des moyens
alloués dans le cadre du renforcement de
la justice de proximité et s'agissant du
stock des affaires je vais vous donner
les chiffres précis
il est passé de
1 million
107 384 c'est le nombre de dossiers qui
étaient en 2021 à 965
3331 en 2021 soit une baisse de 13%. et
la baisse s'accentue encore je n'ai pas
encore les chiffres définitifs mais on a
toutes les raisons de penser sans être
d'un optimisme
déraisonnable que la baisse des stocks
se poursuit c'est vrai également au
pénal dans une moindre mesure et c'est
cohérent parce que c'est aussi ville que
la hausse des moyens était au fond la
plus importante démontrant que
finalement quand on donne les moyens de
la justice ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal
ensuite
la question que vous me posez sur le
plan de transformation numérique
il y a un premier plan de transformation
numérique pour lequel le Parlement nous
a loué 530 millions d'euros ça a permis
la mise à niveau et l'adaptation de ce
qu'on appelle le socle technique 58000
ordinateurs portables 3300
visioconférences la fibre dans toutes
les juridictions lancement de plusieurs
applications PPL en particulier
procédure pénale numérique ce que nous
souhaitons
deuxième plan de transformation
numérique
195 millions pour 2023 renforcer le
socle travaille important sur les débits
réseau notamment pour suivre le travail
sur les applicatifs qui existent déjà
PPN pour Thalys les 56 millions d'euros
restants permettraient de renforcer la
sécurité des systèmes d'information
c'est un sujet crucial et permettrait
également de développer de nouveaux
projets suite aux états généraux de la
justice comme par exemple une plateforme
de gestion des violences intrafamiliales
je dois dire que
au sein du ministère
nous sommes en train de
bouger un certain nombre de lignes qui
pour vous dire vrai n'ont pas été bougé
depuis longtemps
nous avions une critique dont on peut
dire qu'elle était assez serbe et qui
est menée de la cour de comptes qui
elle-même d'ailleurs si j'ose dire
réviser son jugement en tous les cas a
émis un jugement plus clément en disant
que des efforts avaient été faits nous
les poursuivons encore bon un secrétaire
général qui est pratiquement
exclusivement affectée au numérique et
le nouveau secrétariat général est
mobilisé pour régler ces questions parce
que nous savons moi je le dis que nous
n'avons pas toujours été
les meilleurs élèves au ministère de la
Justice et d'ailleurs
ce sont des choses qui n'ont pas échappé
à la sagacité des parlementaires que
vous êtes mais on veut faire un certain
nombre d'efforts il faut que ça marche
mieux on a besoin de ces outils ils sont
indispensables à la simplification et et
franchement nous faisons un certain
nombre d'efforts sur lesquels j'aurai je
n'en doute pas une seconde l'occasion de
revenir parce que je pense que comme
l'année dernière
vous aurez les uns et les autres envie
de m'interroger sur les progrès que
j'annonce dès à présent et que nous
voulons faire de façon ambitieuse sur le
numérique
sur l'exécution du budget du ministère
et de la date
en particulier
le budget de la date est en hausse
et passera de
4,6 milliards en 2022 à 4,9 milliards en
c'est une hausse d'environ 7,5%
s'agissant de de l'exécution du budget
du ministère moins moins de 1% des
crédits votés en loi de finances
initiale n'ont pas été consommés
alors parent et en moyenne sur les 15
dernières années soit environ
100 millions d'euros sur un budget de
9,6 milliards en 2023
c'est assez faible
s'agissant de l'exécution des crédits
immobiliers qui ont été alloués à la DAP
j'arrive encore plus précisément à la
question qui vous préoccupe je reconnais
qu'entre 2017 et 2021 environ 13% de 126
millions sur
un milliard 800 millions d'euros des
crédits votés en faveur de la
construction du plan 15000 n'ont pas été
consommés mais mais
je plaide de larges circonstances
atténuantes pourquoi parce que ça tient
à ce que le début de la mise en oeuvre
du programme a été marquée en
particulier par des recherches foncières
ça c'est la plaie si j'ose dire et c'est
parfois ce qui appelle le plus
à la sécurité parfois ceux qui ont le
discours sécurité le plus
le plus le plus fort
c'est parfois cela qui au moment de ce
que l'on peut appeler
des obligations républicaines ou en tous
les cas
l'envie l'envie de nous permettre de
résorber
le manque de place à la fois et
l'amélioration des conditions détention
c'est parfois cela qui sont les moins
dix ans tout ça vous le savez alors je
vais quand même vous rassurer parce que
ça n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui parce
que comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure l'ensemble des terrains
ont tous été
identifié et les sous-consommations vont
diminuer fortement sur l'immobilier
d'apps sur l'impact de la hausse du coût
des matières premières sur le plan 15000
l'ensemble des chantiers sont réévalués
en continu compte tenu bien sûr de
l'évolution de l'inflation pour chaque
projet il existe une poche
d'aléa qui vise notamment à couvrir
l'évolution des prix sur le Kester je
vous salue vient d'évoquer un sujet dont
je sais qu'il vous tient
particulièrement à cœur
l'exécution des crédits immobiliers
je vous redirai tout à l'heure ce que
j'ai dit sur cette question parce que je
sais qu'elle vous taraude
peu de le dire oui mais je pense avoir
répondu à ses complètement sur le rythme
des recrutements de surveillants et des
difficultés de recrutement je vous
confirme que les recrutements de
surveillance demeurent malgré nos
efforts très compliqués il y a plusieurs
facteurs qui l'expliquent je suis
encombrement carcéral promiscuité qui en
découle qui complique évidemment les
rapports humains
et des grades bien sûr significativement
les conditions de travail des agents
pénitentiaires bon que je veux ici une
fois encore saluer troisième force de
sécurité de notre pays il faut
absolument leur rendre hommage parce que
ils font un métier difficile les métiers
des corps de la filière de surveillance
pénitentiaire évidemment sont exigeants
peu en phase avec les nouvelles attentes
du monde du travail bon il n'y a pas que
dans ce secteur que se pose la question
de l'attractivité
ce n'est pas à vous que je vais le dire
départ à la retraite des agents recrutés
à la fin des années 80 au début des
années 90 n'améliore pas la situation
alors on a fait beaucoup depuis 2017 il
y a un plan
pardon de requalification qui a permis
de passer de 1400 agents de catégorie C
à la catégorie B à partir de 2019
le corps des surveillants est passé de 4
à 3 grades en 2022 tout en maintenant la
catégorie C il y a des revalorisations
indemnitaires importantes la mise en
oeuvre de concours nationaux affectation
locale assortie d'une prime de
fidélisation de 8000 euros la DAP a mis
en place un plan de lutte contre les
violences à renforcer son dispositif
d'accompagnement des personnels victimes
d'agression et il y a eu ça n'a pas pu
vous échapper une campagne de
communication nationale alors il faut
évidemment trouver d'autres réponses
statutaires indemnitaire ça va de soi
amélioration des conditions de travail
76,8 millions d'euros seront dédiés en
2023 au renforcement de la sécurité des
personnels et les établissements
pénitentiaires
l'accompagnement des jeunes
professionnels dans leur installation et
en matière d'accueil des nouveaux
arrivants en établissement par un
accompagnement amélioré voilà ce que
nous
mettons en place
encore un mot encore un mot sur
l'attractivité il y a bien sûr la
question du logement
j'ai initié deux programmes de
construction sur des terrains qui
appartiennent au ministère de la Justice
un Fleury-Mérogis un Savigny-sur-Orge
pour compléter l'offre mise à
disposition des jeunes qui sont affectés
dans cette région dont nous savons
qu'elle est de ce point de vue
particulièrement tendu mais on travaille
également à l'amélioration de l'accès à
la propriété aux agents de catégorie C
la hausse des réservations de logements
en Île-de-France avec
400 415 mise à disposition de logements
pour 2022 et 145 chambres en colocation
et enfin en matière d'action sociale
nous avons augmenté dans la même
proportion
nous l'avons augmenté pardon dans la
même proportion que le budget du
ministère de la Justice et cela
représente 31,3 millions d'euros en 2023
ça permet
de poursuivre des priorités
ministérielles
la restauration réduire les écarts de
tarifs sur le territoire et prendre en
charge l'augmentation de la subvention
interministérielle le logement s'est
ajusté le dispositif du pré bonifié
immobilier pour permettre notamment aux
agents de catégorie C l'accès à la
propriété l'aide à la parentalité en
réservant plus de place en crèche
poursuites et renforcements autant que
de besoin du dispositif d'accompagnement
des agents en difficulté financières
dispositif particulièrement important
dans le contexte de la crise
ensuite Mayotte comme ça je réponds à la
fois Monsieur tany Mohamed Souali et je
vous réponds monsieur sénateur
je me suis déplacé à Mayotte en mars
en mars 2022 ça me paraît plus
vraisemblable monsieur le président
et il y a deux projets immobiliers qui
concernent l'administration
pénitentiaire bon
je dois dire j'ai pas de date précise
parce que vous le dites vous-même je ne
sénateur la question majeure c'est celle
du foncier donc on a mis sous tension
tous les services pour nous trouver les
terrains qui vont bien il y a également
la construction d'une cité judiciaire et
qui ne soit permis une petite parenthèse
je suis un peu hors sujet mais tout de
même pour Mayotte et pour Cayenne nous
avons inventé on réfléchit de temps en
temps puis temps j'entends on est plutôt
fier de notre réflexion pas toujours nos
vins on a inventé des brigades d'urgence
qu'est-ce que c'est que les brigades
d'urgence
il y a un problème d'attractivité sur
ces territoires nous le savons et c'est
évidemment mal vécu par tous ceux qui
rendent la justice à Mayotte à Cayenne
alors
on permet pour une durée de 6 mois
précisément six mois et un jour les
fiscalistes seront pourquoi le jour
supplémentaire s'impose à des magistrats
métropolitains d'aller en urgence
à Cayenne à Mayotte
pour
pallier le manque de magistrats ils ont
ces magistrats la certitude une fois ce
cette période
de six moyens un jour terminé de
retrouver leur poste et nous avons mis
en place tout un système pour dire au
fond au magistrat que être à Mayotte
être à Cayenne ça devait être un temps
un tremplin vous savez nous étions
ensemble il y a aussi la question
évidemment des greffiers qui se posent
et nous mettons en place pour les
greffiers des dispositifs similaires
voilà je ferme la parenthèse je pense
avoir été monsieur le sénateur plutôt
complet et si vous souhaitez d'autres
pressions vous savez je le redis puisque
les choses vont mieux en les disant que
la porte de la Chancellerie évidemment
est grande ouverte madame la sénatrice
Carrère
recrutement dans la PJJ et et taux de
vacances voilà
résumé un peu pardon
la question que qui vous que vous me
posez
alors d'abord on va dire que malgré les
difficultés la continuité du service
public de la PJJ est toujours assurée
dans tous les services et dans toutes
les structures et on va aussi moment est
venu puisque ces deux dont on parle le
rendre un vibrant hommage
sur la question d'attractivité
des évolutions statitaires statutaires
indemnitaires importantes ont été faites
vous savez quand on parle de
l'attractivité l'une des choses
évidemment à laquelle on pense tout de
suite c'est ben oui c'est le salaire
évidemment on n'attire pas les mouches
avec du vinaigre c'est bien humain et
nous aussi c'est à ça auquel on pense on
pense en premier
le passage des éducateurs en catégorie 1
en 2022 non ça ça n'est pas rien le
bénéfice du complément indiciaire acté
en début d'année 2022 aux acteurs du
travail social c'est plus de 2000 euros
par an 2023 on poursuit ses efforts
par des mesures catégorielles dédiées 11
millions d'euros pour 2023 qui
permettront de revaloriser les primes
d'encadrement des structures des agents
contractuels et des mesures
interministérielles un plan d'action
interministériez-vous vous savez est
actuellement en cours d'élaboration sur
les recrutements de la PJJ
ils seront accélérés en passant de 51
effectifs supplémentaires en 2022 à 92
dans le prélève 2023 soit une hausse de
plus de 80% en un an
sève Mayotte peut-être que je peux
répondre sur la question CEF puisque
plusieurs questions m'ont été posées moi
je crois au chef
j'y crois parce que on sait aujourd'hui
est un travail qui a été
préparé par la par la PJJ que 75% des
mineurs délinquants
mettent en application
leur projet professionnel et 86% des
jeunes délinquants qui sont passés par
le CF ne récidivent pas
bon c'est vrai que le chef c'est une
structure lourde en termes
d'accompagnement
mais moi j'ai la conviction que
ça fonctionne et je veux y ajouter le
président de la République l'a exprimé
durant la campagne
un partenariat PJJ militaire
naturellement s'agit pas d'envoyer tous
les gamins qui sont en CF à l'armée
s'il suffisait de les mettre dans un bus
et des envoyer dans les casernes il y
avait le lurette d'abord que nous le
saurions et ça ne peut pas marcher comme
ça d'abord l'expertise doit être
conduite par la PJJ car la PJJ est au
cœur du dispositif mais si un certain
nombre de gamins ont une appétence pour
les valeurs militaires le dépassement de
soi le sport la solidarité etc etc
moi je pense que il est extrêmement
intéressant
de les envoyer dans un stage et j'ai
fait
j'ai réalisé une expérimentation à
couette qui dans
et je dois vous dire que j'ai été très
très impressionné
parce que
on a estimé il y a pas beaucoup de
gamins
que
90% d'entre eux avaient
peut-être subi dans un tout premier
temps puis vécu ce stage comme étant
susceptible de les arracher à la
délinquance
donc on souhaite le le comment dirais
signé convention et on va le faire très
prochainement avec mon ami le Cornu
convention partenariale entre la pjg et
les militaires ça c'est ajouter cette
question du chef alors on en a pour le
moment 53 j'ai inauguré il y a deux
jours un cf
à Saint-Nazaire
à Mayotte
alors pour l'outre-mer pardon il y a
trois sève qui relèvent actuellement du
domaine associatif
à ce stade là cet instant on discute
toujours pour savoir si cette associatif
passe associatif en tous les cas on
s'est engagé pour la création de Joseph
et l'arbitrage sera pris tout à fait
prochainement
bon on échangera évidemment sur cette
question je sais Monsieur de sénateur à
quel point elle vous elle vous tient à
cœur donc au fur et à mesure des
évolutions je vous étiendrai évidemment
strictement strictement informé selon la
formule consacrée mais qui n'est pas
creuse en l'occurrence
madame sénatrice Brigitte l'herbier bon
1500 magistrats est-ce que c'est le bon
chiffre
bon en tous les cas en tous les cas
c'est pas un chiffre comme ça on doit
mouillé c'est d'abord la réflexion des
États généraux dont je vous ai dit que
ils avaient ces états généraux réunis
tout le monde judiciaire
moi je pense que il y a deux façons
de rendre la justice plus plus
protectrice et plus rapide parce que
vous savez que dans ces états généraux
nos compatriotes ont contribué il y a un
million de contributions et il y a deux
items qui reviennent de façon récurrente
le premier c'est la justice n'est pas
suffisamment connue
c'est vrai votre honneur j'ai envie de
dire
les gamins si on leur demande
peut-être même quelques adultes
d'ailleurs qui préside une cour d'assise
répondent c'est votre honneur non la
justice est pas connue elle mérite de
l'être davantage en tous les cas ne
compatriait le disent moi je le pense je
le pensais puisque on a vous avez voté
le texte loi confiance dans lequel il y
avait la mise en place
de la justice filmée bon entre
parenthèses entre parenthèses 23h France
première diffusion 600 000
téléspectateurs
deuxième diffusion sur le civil première
diffusion c'est c'est le pénal ces
audiences correctionnelles en pleine
période de vacances 23 heures 350 000 et
le service public dit que c'est un beau
score donc on essaie je sais pas si vous
l'avez vu mais d'apporter un certain
nombre d'explications pédagogiques avec
Papen DIY on met en place un passeport
éduc droit parce que moi j'aimerais bien
que dans le cours
d'instruction civique on parle un peu de
la justice dans la face mieux connaître
je suis quand même très affolé je
voudrais vous le dire
vous en avez évidemment conscience à la
fois
vous avez ceux qui appellent
à la désobéissance civile c'est-à-dire à
la violation de la loi que vous avez
voté
et puis il y a ceux qui appellent à la
destruction par le truchement de leur
séisme médiatique à la destruction de
l'État de droit c'est encore plus
inquiétant si on franchit ses limites je
pense que nous allons tomber bien bas et
vous avez d'ailleurs de plus en plus de
gens qui disent mais au fond il est
peut-être pas normal qu'on se rendent
justice à soi-même là les choses de
cette nature qui circulent en ce moment
et en particulier parmi la jeunesse moi
je suis très très inquiet de cela donc
je pense qu'il faut faire connaître la
justice
pardon pour cette parenthèse mais elle
me paraît indispensable je pense que
pour la rendre plus efficace et plus
rapide le deuxième item c'est là où je
reprends le
le cours de ma pensée le deuxième item
c'est la justice trop lente trop lente
trop lente c'est pas normal qu'on attend
on comprend pas pourquoi une affaire est
renvoyée pourquoi si pourquoi ça etc bon
et là c'est les moyens l'équipe autour
du magistrat évidemment et c'est aussi
la simplification des procédures civiles
et pénales
donc on envisage sur le plan pénal de
simplifier procédure pénale tout le
monde tout le monde est d'accord avec ça
les forces de sécurité intérieure les
magistrats les avocats et je pense que
si on leur explique les Justiciers ne
sont aussi d'accord avec ça et un
certain nombre de mesures civiles qui
vont permettre de raccourcir je le pense
drastiquement les délais du procès bon
voilà comment on peut
envisager les choses que sur le plan
budgétaire sur le plan humain
sur le plan matériel et aussi en
simplification en simplifiant pardon des
textes qui sont devenus aujourd'hui
extrêmement lourd et qui ne permettent
pas la fluidité qui ne permet pas qui ne
permet pas de de juger aussi vite que
nos compatriotes le souhaiteraient
est-ce que madame la
sénatrice
vous me
j'ai répondu je pense
d'accord alors vous avez raison vous
avez raison vous avez raison bon on a
engagé alors sur l'attractivité j'ai
envie de faire la même réponse que celle
que j'ai fait tout à l'heure
j'ai un peu vulgarisé le propos mais
c'est vrai qu'on attire pas les mouches
avec du vinaigre et la première mesure à
laquelle on change pour l'attractivité
c'est une mesure salariale indiciaire
etc bon
on a eu dans les ces pipes 1500
recrutements depuis 2018 ce qui d'abord
a permis de diminuer le nombre de
dossiers suivis par agent ça aussi mais
alors
je le concède mais je le conseille mais
je le conseille mais c'est dans une
moyenne alors évidemment une moyenne bon
voilà passer de 80 à 71
c'est pas la même chose
80 dossiers 71 dossiers par
non mais je dis pas c'est une moyenne
c'est une moyenne
bon on a mis en place
pour aider nos organigrammes de
référence et je pense que il disent
très objectivement vous me le conseiller
d'ailleurs
que ça les a aidés ce qui est quand même
le but
en termes de revalorisation les CIPS ont
vu alors passage en catégorie A
revalorisation indemnitaire 220 euros
par mois en 2022
qu'est-ce qu'on compte faire pour rendre
le métier des dépits plus attractifs
alors il y a des réformes
interministérielles qui ont été engagés
depuis 2017 qui ont abouti à revaloriser
des salaires des conseillers
mais pas ceux des directeurs
et
il en est de même d'ailleurs pour les
directeurs de services de la Protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse alors
concernant les dépits puisque c'est le
sujet de votre question le ministère
s'engage en 2022 à revalorisé les primes
des dépipes d'environ
70 7 pardonnez-moi 700 000 euros qui
viennent s'ajouter aux 600 000 euros qui
ont été octroyés à ce corps en 2021
et en 2023
je portais porter la poursuite de la
hausse des primes à hauteur de d'un
million
une réforme du statut pour faciliter la
promotion professionnelle et des
parcours de carrière plus attractifs et
enfin une revalorisation de leur
rémunération indiciaire à hauteur de
1,3 millions je pense là vous avez
répondu
si vous souhaitez plus de précisions la
porte de la Chancellerie voilà je vous
le redis on regarde ça
bien sûr
non mais vous avez vous avez raison mais
ça fait partie quand même
oui ça fait quand même partie j'ai dit
tout à l'heure je pense qu'objectivement
au première chose au première chose au
pluriel auquel on pense des
revalorisations
monsieur le sénateur sur
alors vous vous me posez évidemment la
question la plus difficile bon
alors c'est moi qui suis interrogé c'est
la règle du jeu ce soir mais moi j'ai
presque envie de vous dire et et vous
comme proposez-vous bon d'abord on dit
alors certains disent vous a pas échappé
c'est Taubira empire bon
c'est un laxiste voilà
les mêmes qui d'ailleurs cet après-midi
à l'Assemblée nationale c'est assez
drôle
mon projet la surpopulation pénale je
dis c'est déjà la démonstration de ce
qu'il y a pas de laxisme bon d'ailleurs
les chiffres sur le laxisme on va se
dire les choses très clairement il
démontre à l'évidence et sans aucune
ambiguïté possible que la justice est
plus sévère aujourd'hui qu'autrefois
qu'il s'agisse des peines
correctionnelles
magistrats professionnels ou qu'il
s'agisse des peines criminelles jury
populaire c'est clair alors d'aucun
ne veulent pas l'entendre parce qu'ils
en font leur tambouille
bullistes c'est la réalité donc les
réponses qu'est-ce que c'est au fond
vous savez je pense monsieur le sénateur
qu'on n'est pas les premiers à se poser
la question non j'ai lu quand j'étais
étudiants droit puis quand j'étais
avocats beaucoup d'ouvrages sur cette
question de l'incarcération par quoi on
la remplace etc de théorie bon la
réalité à laquelle nous nous heurtons
nous interdit la fantaisie il faut être
réaliste qu'est-ce que c'est les
réponses c'est la création
de place nouvelle
bon alors
j'étais en présence d'un grand
journaliste
je le crois
un peu de votre obédience
n'est pas une injure dans la bouche
non non mais pas du tout
sensibilité je prenais le comme vous
voulez c'est moi je suis un gentil
garçon
donc tout ce que je dis n'est pas une
attaque à dominante
et et il me disait mais alors le
problème c'est que plus vous allez
construire prison plus ça se remplit au
fond la nature judiciaire a horreur du
vide mais j'y mets alors qu'est-ce que
vous me proposez je lui dis de ne pas en
construire donc on reste là il manque
des places la surpopulation comment la
règle moi je pense qu'il y a plusieurs
choses qui doivent être conduites en
parallèle il y a ça il y a l'application
du bloc Pen pardon nous dire les
aménagements à bénissions le travail
d'intérêt général auquel je crois moi le
travail d'intérêt général ça marche on a
favorisé
360 c'est un bel outil
dont je pense on ne s'empare pas
suffisamment mais vous savez par
ailleurs que
la justice est indépendante alors moi je
peux évoquer deux ou trois choses auprès
des procureurs leur suggérer leur
susurrer peut pas en faire beaucoup plus
mais pour le reste ensuite les juges du
siège
ils prononcent des peines qu'ils ont
envie de prononcer moi je veux bien
endosser toutes les responsabilités mais
en même temps
je souhaite que les choses soient
clarifiées la justice de notre pays est
indépendance indépendante il faut
qu'elle le reste d'ailleurs
mais on a cette difficulté les
récurrentes bon
il y a aussi peut-être disons les choses
une certaine augmentation de la
délinquance encore que vous voyez
tout est nuancé la délinquance des
mineurs sur les chiffres qui m'ont été
communiqués semblent en baisse mais mais
on peut pas faire cocorico en disant
code de justice pénale des mineurs que
vous avez voté d'ailleurs à l'unanimité
ce texte a permis la baisse de la
délinquance des mineurs on peut pas dire
ça c'est pas sérieux de dire ça non mais
on peut pas danser les populistes et
puis se servir de chiffres comme ça à
l'envie sans avoir une expertise assez
fine il n'en reste pas moins vrai qu'un
certain nombre d'indicateurs permettent
avec toute la prudence de penser que la
délinquance des mineurs est en baisse
bon
et puis et puis disons-le franchement la
société est aussi de plus en plus dure
et demande de plus en plus de répression
bon ça aussi une traduction judiciaire
qu'on le veuille ou non voilà ce que je
peux vous dire bon donc moi vous voyez
travail d'intérêt général oui évidemment
200% il faut les développer je me
déplace beaucoup pour signer des
conventions partenariales pour que on
nous propose de plus en plus de choses
en la matière on a déjà beaucoup plus de
tiges disponibles aujourd'hui que
autrefois et puis quand même moi j'ai vu
l'évolution j'ai connu le travail
d'intérêt général à sa création quand il
était prononcé dites moi on savait même
pas s'il serait exécuté on sait même pas
s'il y avait un travail d'intérêt
général à disposition aujourd'hui on
sait parce qu'on a une plateforme
auquel les avocats ont accès d'ailleurs
j'ai souhaité qu'il puisse accéder à la
plateforme comme ça ils peuvent plaider
le l'application du travail d'intérêt
général donc quelque chose qui est
taillé sur mesure pour leurs clients
donc moi monsieur le sénateur sur si
vous avez la solution miracle surtout
vous pourrez me voir vous le savez
d'ailleurs votre question vous la posez
avec beaucoup de nuances je vous en
remercie c'est infiniment compliqué bon
oui mais la régulation elle peut pas se
faire n'importe comment il y a un
certain nombre de projets qui sont
proposés où on a par exemple j'entends
j'entends que l'extrême droite dit
souvent mais il y a des gens qui sortent
parce que vous l'avez demandé parce que
il y a pas de place dans les prisons
c'est absolument faux vous ne trouverez
aucune circulaire rien ne ma part disant
on met pas en prison parce que on est
dans la surpopulation absolument pas
absolument pas bon
mais
pour le reste il y a un certain nombre
de choses qui nous sont proposées moi
sur lesquelles je tique par exemple
interdire l'incarcération en raison du
fait que les prisons sont pleines ce
serait pour moi d'abord
anticonstitutionnel bon
voilà
je pense mais moi vous savez je suis
très ouvert à la discussion
très bien
ouais la différence des prisons bon
monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
sénateur tanimoids
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure d'ailleurs en
parlant de prison que la transition
comme
la transition est toute trouvée vous
savez que on cherche le terrain voilà
tous les feux sont au vert pour le CEF
je m'y suis engagé pour la cité
judiciaire je pense qu'on a trouvé
puisque lorsque j'ai fait le déplacement
à Mayotte on a réussi à convaincre le
président du département
il nous
on a réussi ça quand même c'était pas
rien ça n'était pas gagné à l'avance
mais voilà je pense que les choses
avancent et pour le reste vous donner
une temporalité là pour le moment je
vous mentirai si je vous disais telle
date parce que voilà pas envie de vous
raconter l'histoire je sais que la
situation Mayotte est trop sérieuse pour
que l'on annonce des choses que l'on
tiendra mais que je suis incapable de
comment dirais-je définir dans le dans
le temps Madame madame de La Gontrie
sur le sur les juridictions spécialisées
alors
oui mais il faut répondre aux deux donc
peu importe sur les juridictions
spécialisées
bon
alors c'est une question à ce point
complexe moi d'abord je ne suis contre
rien je le dis très clairement
les Espagnols ont fait une juridiction
spécialisée
ils n'en sont pas à 100% satisfait parce
que pour des raisons notamment
géographiques
ça discute c'est la raison pour laquelle
la première ministre a lancé commission
de travail confiée à des parlementaires
dans Madame Dominique Verrien je sais
toujours pas si elle est là ou si elle
n'est plus là ou si elle était là bon on
va attendre on va attendre que tout cela
nous revienne en regardera moi je n'ai
aucun a priori si je suis évidemment
convaincu que c'est la meilleure des
solutions moi j'essaie de d'être pratico
pratique je suis pas un idéologue
et on ira vers cette on ira vers cette
vers cette solution
mais
oui enfin vous savez alors
oui mais attendez
dans une juridiction
vous avez déjà un certain nombre ou ça
coûte rien
ça coûte pas plus en tous les cas parce
que les magistrats sont déjà ils
s'occupent déjà des vifs c'est une super
spécialisation mais en réalité
budgétairement je pense que ça n'a pas
d'impact d'ailleurs votre sourire me
démontre que
ça c'est autre chose
on attend
on attend le travail par le montant
et puis on verra et d'ailleurs je pense
qu'on le verra ensemble évidemment parce
que c'est une question importante bon
perspective pour 2023 crédit consacrés
victimes de vif
16,2 millions d'euros une hausse de 5%
par rapport à 2022 et de plus de 50% par
rapport à 2021 avec ça on va déployer
tout au long de l'année 5000 téléphones
graves danger
généralise supplémentaire bien sûr
pardon le supplémentaire me fait penser
que je n'ai pas complètement répondu à
votre question c'est 1500 magistrats en
plus net
ça veut dire que non pas que je perds un
peu la tête mais que je
suis pas en grande forme que ce soit
mais bon voilà bon
généraliser l'évolution des besoins de
protection et en particulier au moment
de la sortie de détention des auteurs de
violence on sait d'ailleurs à ce propos
que j'ai pris un décret pour que de
façon obligatoire les les femmes soient
averties de la sortie de leur compagnon
ou avec ce compagnon
violent renforcer l'accompagnement et
suivi des victimes bénéficiants du TGD
et du bar évidemment et développer les
permanences spécialisées
des associations dont les lieux tiers
comme les commissariats les brigades de
gendarmerie les hôpitaux voilà
bien merci
monsieur le ministre pour ce premier
point reste les deux sujets de nos
rapporteurs sur la police judiciaire si
on peut avoir deux questions ou une
question courte alors
elle se lance monsieur le ministre
question courte donc sur la réforme de
la police nationale les magistrats comme
vous le savez ça ne savait bien
craignent une disparition de la police
judiciaire alors première question
courte est-ce que vous partagez leurs
inquiétudes de voir disparaître la
police judiciaire
et
vous m'entend on recommence
bon alors je continue sur cette question
et dans quelle mesure parce qu'on a
rencontré des magistrats mais dans
quelle mesure pouvez-vous nous dire les
magistrats peuvent-ils d'ores et déjà
rencontré des difficultés pour le
traitement de dossier du fait de manque
de disponibilité des enquêteurs est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui maintenant et un manque
que vous vous voilà juste et la deuxième
chose mais voilà je sais que le ministre
de l'Intérieur vous a écrit pour vous
parler de cette réforme mais et pour
vous vous indiquez aussi répondre aux
craintes des magistrats de n'avoir à
saisir que le directeur départemental et
donc il vous a écrit pour vous dire que
la réforme avait pour objectif d'offrir
davantage de lisibilité à l'autorité
judiciaire qui pourrait saisir le chef
de la circonscription la police
nationale ou chef de la police
judiciaire ou alors à ce moment-là le
directeur départemental ou directeur
zonal bon est-ce que
cette réponse du ministre de l'Intérieur
semble vous répondre aux inquiétudes
est-ce que ça semble répondre aux
inquiétudes des magistrats qu'ils ont pu
exprimer à avoir à saisir le directeur
départemental de la police nationale et
également selon vous donc est-ce qu'il
serait
contenu de cet ordre à saisir et ce qui
utile nécessaire je ne sais pas de
modifier le terme de formation dans
l'article 12 du code de procédure pénale
qui laisse le libre choix des formations
chargées des enquêtes est-ce qu'à votre
avis cette cette modification semblerait
utile dans le cadre de cette réforme et
préviendrait préciser la saisine des
différents échelons merci madame le
rapporteur monsieur Durand peut-être oui
merci Monsieur président monsieur le
ministre
on a eu des échanges assez longs avec le
ministre Darmanin sur les raisons de la
grogne bon beaucoup de raisons peuvent
l'expliquer notamment des questions de
forme
enfin cette constater que une nouvelle
instance s'est créée dans la police
judiciaire qui connaît un certain succès
la MPJ que du côté du monde de la
justice entre guillemets la mobilisation
est assez importante quand même avec des
instances qui ne sont pas anecdotiques
qui se sont positionnés évidemment le
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature la
conférence des procureurs des procureurs
généraux avec une forme de gravité de
solennité qui n'a échappé à personne et
une inquiétude qui est sincère pour tous
ceux que nous avons déjà auditionné il y
a deux points qui retiennent l'attention
dans la réforme le risque d'abandon du
haut du spectre de la criminalité tout
ce qui est criminator organisé tout ce
qui est
à faire complexe qui sont
interrégionales internationales pour
voir pour des raisons d'encadrement des
raisons de compétences une partie des
effectifs d'un collier judiciaire
s'orienter vers la délinquance de masse
et la résorption du stock important
d'affaires qu'on connaît partout dans le
territoire la deuxième inquiétude qui se
manifeste c'est une inquiétude qui tient
à une
une intervention qui pourrait être celle
de la sphère administrative dans la
sphère judiciaire avec la
tutelle du préfet possible sur les ddpn
du coup bah on voulait vraiment vous
entendre sur cet aspect là c'est
important et qui me concerne pas que les
affaires politiquesment sensibles dont
on parle beaucoup et puis
peut-être
accessoirement vous dire quand même que
la question de la procédure pénale est
évoquée et de sa complexité et évoqué à
toutes les auditions à toutes les
auditions par toutes les parties nous
entendons et puis peut-être vous
demander aussi pour terminer c'est
vraiment la dernière question ce que
vous avez vous même ressenti des
expérimentations qui ont été conduites à
la fois outre-mer et dans les
départements français merci sur la
porteur deux interventions des questions
vous savez la parole
bon je pense qu'il y a il y a deux
sujets
l'un qui me concerne et l'autre qui ne
me concerne pas le volet réorganisation
de la PJ en tant que tel c'est du périmé
du périmètre strict du ministère de
l'Intérieur
si demain on souhaite créer une
juridiction je pense que
c'est du périmètre strict du ministère
de la Justice
dont je n'ai pas à me prononcer sur ce
volet là sauf que je pense que il y a un
certain nombre de vrais raisons qui
peuvent amener Gérald Darmanin à vouloir
mieux structurer les choses
ensuite il y a un volet qui nous est
commence et j'ose dire
et pour lequel nous serons d'une
certaine façon cosignataire
nous avons d'abord travaillé ensemble
le DGPN et le dacg ont travaillé
ensemble quelle est la ligne rouge
en franchissable pour le ministère de la
Justice
c'est les dispositions de l'article 12
du code de procédure pénale mais ça
tombe au fond très bien parce que c'est
aussi une ligne rouge infranchissable
pour le ministre de l'intérieur alors il
m'a écrit en réalité il m'a répondu
parce que on a entendu un certain nombre
de critiques
parfois singulière je dois le dire parce
que au fond
certains ont crié aïe avant de recevoir
un coup que personne ne souhaitait leur
porter
et on a entendu certains au magistrats
s'exprimaient notamment
sur des radios nationales pour dire que
la réforme n'était pas bonne de vous à
moi c'est législateur qui dessine une
réforme est bonne ou pas et c'est lui
qui la vote bon
peu importe disons que chacun s'exprime
avec liberté
mais moi quand j'ai vu
ces critique je les ai évidemment
entendus j'ai été très attentif à tout
ça
j'ai dit mais
le ministre de l'Intérieur ne veut en
aucune façon empiéter sur les
prérogatives qui sont celles des
magistrats depuis des temps immémoriaux
parce que le juge d'instruction par
exemple choisit son enquêteur son
service d'enquête
mais surtout
quand je dis que certains
crient avant d'avoir reçu un coup
personne ne veut porter il y a une
expérimentation
qui n'est pas encore terminée
et expérimentation au sens que lui donne
le Conseil d'État parce que je ne serai
pas démenti
ça nécessite une évaluation
c'est pas un truc comme ça et vanessant
l'expérimentation il faut tirer les
conséquences d'une expérimentation sinon
ça sert à rien d'expérimenter et
voyez-vous il y a une
inspection j'ai presque envie de dire
une triple inspection puisque il y a
l'inspection d'une part va pas d'une
part c'est la même
igji inspection générale de la justice
GPN et Iger donc
ce triptyque-là nous assure encore plus
que qu'elle habitude
l'impartialité évidemment des
inspecteurs donc on aura les résultats
de cette analyse de cette inspection
nous ne les avons toujours pas et je
pense que il ministre de l'Intérieur et
et moi-même et sans doute nous deux
ensemble nous tirerons de ces
inspections un certain nombre de
conséquences mais moi je n'ai aucun
doute je pense que la machine parfois
s'emballe un peu vite que l'on peut
avoir un certain nombre de crainte
mais pour le reste rien ne me permet de
penser
que l'article 12 sera abogée modifié et
de mon côté j'ai dit au ministre de
l'intérieur mais il a évidemment entendu
et c'est la réponse qu'il m'a adressé
moi qui me qui me satisfait totalement
car je n'ai jamais pensé que il peut en
être autrement il peut en être autrement
pardon voilà nous nous allons vers
quelque chose ou chacun
sera respectueux de
du choix du magistrat quand au service
d'enquête moi j'ai aucune aucune
difficulté je n'ai personnellement
strictement aucune crainte sur ces
questions voilà
bien merci monsieur le ministre de votre
présence ce soir et des informations que
vous nous avez données nous allons lever
la séance je rappelle le commissaire aux
lois que nous ne retrouvons demain matin
à 9h Merci à VOUS bonne soirée